hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast introduction to the new USP
787 sub visible particulate matter and
sera Punic protein injections I am Judy
O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by Beckman Coulter life
sciences ethnic culture life sciences is
the premier global supplier of
instruments for particle counting and
particle characterization in the
nanometers for visible and visible
ranges support its customers the best
known culture brands net1 Hayek and
Coulter are vastly a global service
organization for more information please
visit the Beckman Coulter particle
counting and characterization website
WWL comm we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to the Interactive's
do we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green 2 + 8 button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
sharing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker
Joe Getty Joe has been involved with
particle counters in characterization
since 1984 while his degree in
electrical engineering electronic
engineering has given him a good insight
into the design of these instruments it
is his continuous involvement in the
real-life application of particle
counters in a broad range of industries
that has enabled him to relate to the
users and to promote the efficient
application of Compendium methods Joe
has participated in a number of
standards organizations and activities
including the ASTM committee on testing
students and the IES P Committee on
calibration methods you recently
participated in the is OTC 209 working
group one Committee for the revision of
the ISO one
four six four four - one clean room
classification standard one of the two
Americans on that committee he is also a
member of the ISO TC 24 group working on
standards and methods for particle
counters and particle characterization
Joe is based in the United States and
the beautiful mountains of Southern
Oregon I will now turn it over to Jo
Getty for his presentation
yes thanks Judy
good morning and thank you for joining
us I want to cover the most recent
introduction of a particle accounting
method from the American USP called USP
787 and it addresses some of the issues
that people have had concerning the
sampling of proteins in the final
product mode so we'll cover a little bit
of the history of the injectable product
testing as well as kind of defined some
of the terms that are used visible sub
visible y 787 came about by reviving the
previous methods were not quite
appropriate how it's different from the
788 a lot of people are familiar with
and then also comparing it to the
general information chapter 1787 and
looking to follow through with alternate
methods and technologies that could be
used for the examination of proteins so
first a bit of history
well injectables have been tested for
quite a while and various methods
certainly in the earlier days with
microscopes then fold with the concerns
or the methods of optical particle
counting the main concern though
initially was any objects that might
affect the human blood stream and the
main concern there is that capillaries
are quite small they're down in the ten
micron or so range to allow blood vessel
but red blood cells with about five
microns to pass through and so anything
that might be introduced into the
bloodstream it would be 10 microns or
larger within a potentially block or
occlude the capillaries and of course
that's not a positive thing for people's
health so there's a lot of focus then
done on the restriction and control of
10 micron larger particles so that's
where a lot of the original design was
and of course ultimately the concern is
someone ultimately gets your therapy the
injection and in many cases the person
has already compromised health so if you
put something directly into the
bloodstream that's not beneficial it's
not intense the full therapy that is
intended well that's not the best thing
for their recovery so that's been a lot
of the focus how do you keep unwanted
insoluble chunks of material out of the
injections and those could be regular
injections you might get in the doctor's
office or it could be in a hospital
setting with an IV drip either of those
are introducing materials into the
bloodstream directly and those are the
greatest concerns the greatest focus of
the regulatory agencies with any kind of
injection to the body of course has some
risk and some constraints of major focus
of course has been towards the actual
introduction introduction directly into
the bloodstream so you know the FDA the
American FDA talks about that is
contamination or belter ation partly
because it's something that wasn't
intended it was introduced but certainly
because of the concerns with the
blockage of blood vessels thicker
capillaries all kinds of things have
been found in history in IVs today of
course filtering methods and control
methods are much more strict and
carefully observed and in times past but
all the forms and materials coming from
the process and from the environment
around the process steps how the
containers are being filled and so forth
can potentially introduce contamination
so these evolved in the focus of some of
the concerns with regulatory agencies
and some of the controls they put in
place the primary method for looking at
the final product has been since about
the 1960s the optical particle counter
light obscuration rlo method and there
has been a unique effort in this
industry to harmonize the methods from
the u.s. from the Europe from Europe
from Japan from Korea and now even with
with China trying to come with a
consistent method globally for this
critical test of injectable materials
the secondary method is the optical
little trusty optical microscope and why
not light microscopes are wonderful but
they are very slow they're somewhat
dependent on the skill of the observer
and also of course over time in a day
for eight hours looking through a
microscope probably the ability to
analyze not as good as when one was
fresh at the very beginning so the
optical particle counter has served very
well in industry to provide a consistent
repeatable method for determination of
particles in injectable materials so we
have these pharmacopoeia methods the USP
seven eight eight the European p2 or
nine nineteen Japanese 607 Korea and 51
and so forth that all basically have the
same method the same steps to test that
and the same limits somewhat more
recently the Chinese method was
introduced and it's notable mainly
because it also discussed biologics this
is kind of the first discussion that was
brought out it was introduced in 2010
and it strictly focused on intravenous
injections and they did make as I said a
separate
chapter now the wording turns out to be
the same at the moment but it kind of
laid the groundwork ground for looking
at biologics in a different way and the
USP has been engaged for a number of
years already in discussions with the
industry and a focus towards trying to
find a better method to deal with
biologics in particular with protein
solutions so when we talk about these
various methods there's been certainly a
lot of focus recently with USP 790 and
similar methods for visible particles so
there's a lot of discussion about that
this particular attractor has to do with
some visible and so how does that kind
of define what does that mean well in a
lot of cases people think of the ability
of the human eye to see small objects
and it kind of gets to a limit down
around 35 to 50 microns that's about the
best the unaided human eye can do and so
most people tend to think of that as the
constraints of visible sub visible it
turns out though in the Compendium
methods in the USP in particular they
speak of visible starting at about a
hundred microns and sub visible as being
that range a couple decades below that
from about one to two microns up to a
hundred microns and then below that we
have sub micron or an animator below the
one micron range so so visible as this
chapter applies is mainly focused in
that range from 1 up to 100 microns in
size and if we look at the current
limits that have been posted for 10 and
25 microns that fits into this sub
missable range so we're looking for
things that the human eye normally
cannot see but are of concern once they
get into the body so I have a new
chapter what's the focus for 787 well
fundamentally it's addressing the needs
particularly of the production and
testing of protein based therapeutics
and it's looking at the final dose and
packaging of it it allows the use of
smaller test volumes which is kind of
the critical point for a lot of people
in the industry the amount of material
needed to test under 788 was significant
typically 25 milliliters and that can be
quite an expensive test to execute at
that volume also you can use under 787
smaller amounts of material to carry out
the analysis so no longer does it have
to be a 5 milliliter pull it can be a
smaller amount and this again is a cost
savings and also a nod to the fact that
most of the therapeutic doses for
protein-based materials are relatively
small and we're talking often less even
than one milliliter for an injection it
also speaks in about inherent form a
particular matter that had not been
really brought to the fore before and as
you'll see and it goes through and of
course describes a bit more the
preparation in tests and those are
different from the existing 788 method
for general injectables and of course it
defines the maximum limits of the
particle burden for our therapeutics
again please note that this is focused
on proteins is for protein based
therapeutics does not generally apply to
all forms and injectables so what is the
same well first off the primary method
is still the light obscuration device
light obscuration sensors have been used
again in this methodology since the
1960s and that continues to be the
primary method used very repeatable and
that's one of the values very fast or
repeatable of course still there's some
types of materials that are difficult to
test in that manner so light microscopy
is offered as its secondary method
should the primary method based on light
observation not be appropriate for a
certain material there's still a minimum
number of tests to polls for a loquats
needed but they can be now much smaller
as well
the sizes of interest still 10 and 25
microns and the limits look the same
really as you'll see there's a slight
variation when we look at the large
volume but basically you're looking at
limits of 600 for 25 micron 6000 for 10
micron in small volume and large volume
25 at 10 micron 3 4 ml at 25 micron so
the same limits as 788 but again the
problem was 788 for some of this very
expensive material is the cost of the
test under 788 and some of the ways that
the handling of that test material was
done is not appropriate for proteins as
we'll see so 787 has been introduced
it's been effective for under USP from
August first in 2014 and it looks a
little bit like as I said 788 however
the size of the alcohol can be down to
0.2 to the liters and you can also then
do environment tests based more on the
actual size of samples you'll be taking
and those could be certainly less than
the 10 mil tense for environments that
is in the current 788 method so it's
basically a set as counts per ml for the
environment test so what are the
challenges why have this methodology
what's the value well certainly all
forms of handling can change protein
based material it likes to wrap around
itself or other other items so silicon
oil beads anything else can cause it to
form other bodies besides the primary
material so a lot of agitation can cause
aggregation of the product heat life can
affect it more readily various
contaminants as it said silicon oil or
little bits of material can form seeds
that the protein then wraps around the
various types of containers and methods
have an effect on it the more children
on regular small molecules therapeutic
doses sheer forces can affect now this
much more readily the way you pump
material things into various parts of
the process can be significant
the real key concern for most of the
regulatory agencies is concerned with
the aggregation the forming of different
constructions of the protein rather than
the original intended protein material
and again this can happen very easily
and in the body it can change the
reaction it can either change or create
a immediate reaction immune reaction or
it may trigger overtime immunogenicity
that slowly makes the therapeutic effect
of a particular medicine much less so
over time so the concern then is how do
we monitor that certainly in the process
you look at how to control it we do even
after that how do you deal with it
because again you're changing the data
form and maybe you're getting proteins
to wrap around themselves so it's
homogeneous it's the same material or it
might be wrapped around something else a
bit of glass a bit of silicon oil
something else foreign wraps around it
so it makes a heterogeneous aggregate in
the process but any of these are really
something that you want to minimize it's
hard to avoid it entirely but certainly
minimize as much as possible as I
mentioned before we discussed the
inherent type of contamination that's a
new kind of Third Point that's more
prominent out it's always been of some
concern but now with proteins much more
so so the three different types are
extrinsic intrinsic and inherent we'll
touch on each one of these the first two
extrinsic and intrinsic are the ones
that have been most commonly focused
extrinsic is something that you really
can't relate to
process and it might be cellulose that
might be something from outside and room
gypsum or paper that should not be there
at all
in the process and is not expected at
all
intrinsic is looking at things that well
okay you don't want them but could be
results of the process it might be bits
of metal from a filling needle that
scraped the glass a little bit or might
be a bit of glass that is left in the
container due to improper washing or
some other form of something related to
the process so though that's one form
again a second form of contamination
that could occur this third forming
inherent is somewhat of a new term but
again has been discussed in previous
times but without the same kind of focus
or spotlight you could say that is
brought about when discussing proteins
and often then it really relates to
material reforming itself in one way or
another as an aggregate or even maybe
disassociating into some other broken
form you could say oh the original
protein from in 787 which is a
informational chapter we'll touch on in
a moment in 780 1787 it speaks about
materials that are expected from the
drug substance and thus represent a
potentially acceptable characteristic of
the product and of course it's
potentially acceptable doesn't mean that
it's good or in terms of long term
therapy might not trigger immunogenicity
or some other reaction that is not
therapeutic so inherent but
contamination so we often talk about
contamination thinking about something
external here we're thinking about
something that is in a sense a creation
of the material itself and proteins
easily wrap around themselves so it's a
shift from the native form so we're
worried about is different structures
dimers
other members other kinds of protein
complexes that we really would prefer
not to be there and in small quantities
probably not a problem in larger
quantities can be much more so so
there's a focus in 787 more on both the
sample and system preparation then
before was with more simple small
molecule preparations so how is that a
bit different well when you look at 788
it says please you know mix well a sonic
8 and so forth so you'll invert slowly
try not to introduce gas you want to
shake it will invert slowly and you
Sonic 8 the material to kind of break
things up and change it however that's a
concern with the proteins what you're
trying to do is not add entrained gas by
agitating too much you don't want to
shake it and sonication is a form of
shaking you might say for proteins so
it's education is adding kinetic energy
into the into the solution or suspension
and then changes easily than the
material so that's problematic so how
can you deal with entrained gas it make
me some in the material and as you're
analyzing it might bring micro bubbles
out well unlike vacuum seems to be a
good way to deal with that and so it
talks about it using like vacuum you
might use the old-fashioned Bell Jar or
maybe a more current desiccation chamber
or something where you can draw a light
vacuum on the material and bring any of
the entrained gas out of solution and
therefore minimize any analytical error
due to micro bubbles so degassing is a
general term used and so eliminating gas
bubbles and as it's spoken about in 787
talks about then a light vacuum about 75
tour very clearly states sonication
should be avoided so again a fairly
different approach to working with
material for proteins
in 788 they talk about inverting gently
inverting the packaging whether it's a
vial or whatever materials working with
and then it says you know to sonica in
788 here in 787 very clearly at a
different direction and they say very
directly inversion to mix the product
fluid is not recommended at any time so
again different handling for this
protein-based material dilution a lot of
materials are thick or maybe highly
concentrated or both and in some cases
you cannot introduce it easily into a
light obscuration system due to new
those factors so maybe dilution is
necessary under 787 they do discuss that
and they say that the effort to dilute
needs to be carefully done there's quite
a bit of discussion of that in the
informational chapter two in 1787
because by diluting a protein-based
material you may cause disassociation or
potentially aggregation just depending
on the type of formula and various other
aspects of the material so a little
dilution is allowed but it must be
carefully done what about the overall
system and set up to execute the system
well normally when you're working with
light obscuration counters or actually
any other counter so you do two things
first off you want to start out and say
is everything running right so in the
beginning before you do a series of
tests maybe at the beginning of the day
or beginning of a
afternoon operator you run a couple of
tests solutions you run a blank
something that tells you yes it will
effectively read a very very low count
if not zero and then you give it some
kind of a challenge with a known value
of counts in the approximate range of
interest and you might do those then in
the beginning morning it might be also
the only user system once a week okay
before you start that process you do a
couple of these verification steps it's
not a calibration let's a check it's a
health check for the system to give you
confidence that it is going to function
correctly and the results can be
considered accurate in system eight it's
in 787 system preparation is stated in
the same form although for the tests of
materials they talk about system
suitability and they recommend using the
USP PCRs and that stands for a particle
count reference standard so it's a
material of a known quantity at a
certain size typically then 15 microns
and about 3,800 counts per milliliter or
the system says you go that the method
says you can use an alternate so you
might find certainly commercial material
available that would give you the same
basic level of confidence that yes if
you present a certain level of material
the system will read it if you give it a
1000 counts per ml material it will read
approximately 1000 counts as you begin
the process and therefore you have
confidence that whatever might be in
your test solution will be accurately
represented so again 787 a little bit
different and you can run smaller
material smaller amounts of material the
current systems today allow you to run
down accurately to about 0.2 MLS of
material on each Pole
you still need four poles so that could
be then about point eight of material
typically would be about one milliliter
of material to four point
out of in a system when we go through
all this and we evaluate the results how
do we look at that
well again the limits are the same as in
788 with the exception that for large
volumes it needs to also meet a
container test well this is a bit new
there was certainly a container test
before for any materials under 25 MLS
actually under 100 MLS but now all
greater than 100 needs to pass a
container test too
so there could be a let's say a 1 liter
of 1000 milliliter IV solution bag found
and and you've created that or load it
with a protein-based material that whole
container then needs to be tested in
terms of counts per ml and also in terms
of a total container maximum amount of
ink of contaminant recorded at 10
microns cannot exceed 6,000 pounds and
at 25 microns cannot exceed 600 counts
so this is the variation you could say
on the numbers otherwise you're kind of
following 788 especially for small
containers so let's talk a little bit
about light obscuration a little bit
about the methods very briefly and maybe
something you're familiar with and may
not but light obscuration has been
around as I said for quite a few number
of years and it's also sometimes been
referred to as light extinction or light
walking and it gives good information
starting from about one micron up
through several hundred microns depends
on the exact design of sensor but
somewhere in that range it really gives
good results for any kind of foreign
material or object in a liquid one
the good things analytically about this
is first off it's very quick the answer
is given really in seconds there's no
need to add chemicals so it's not an
analytical process where you have to
sting something or I do other some other
analytical step preceding it there
really aren't any other consumables and
most importantly the results are very
repeatable using the method and
reproducible between different machines
because in many cases a facility might
have more than one instrument and of
course you want the instruments to
record the same results the important
thing to realize is that we're dealing
with very irregular forms of material
and we talk about particles with a
certain size we use one dimension to
record these that's an interesting
aspect when most of these particles in
fact are very much three-dimensional so
we're going to sample this what do we do
well first off we have a pathway but the
liquid flows through so we have a
channel and then on each side of this
channel we put a couple of windows we
put a light source - typically today
it's a laser diode we shine a light
through - a detector on the opposite
side and we look for anything that comes
between and modifies the being creates
shadows you could say on the detector so
the detector is normally sitting there
with bright light shining on it so it
has a high level in its normal
uninterrupted state and then when you
introduce a particle into the system it
obscures or blocks it creates a shadow
on the detector it may not totally block
it unless it's a very very large
particle but in most cases it simply
creates a shadow passing over the
surface and that shadow diminishes light
and therefore we can detect it and the
larger the particle degrees the
of light the bigger the shadow so we can
until a the quantity and be the size of
that object as it passes through and we
correlate that are related to
calibration materials so again
larger the particle the more significant
signal we get from the particle in the
in the channel this is an optical
instrument so we use light to detect it
we need to push or pull fluid through
the sensor depending on the design from
light scattering through my obscuration
optical particle counters can see down
into the nanometers and fairly large
size up to several hundred or if not
several thousand microns but that
depends on the design of the sensor it
does count particles individually okay
that's one of the key things about
particle counters as a design they're
really looking specifically at events
one at a time
within reasonable concentration we
cannot tell you the competition we can't
say oh that's a bit of aluminum or
that's a bacterium or something but the
results are immediate and can quickly
quantify the material that might be in
suspension in a particular test fluid
common design the high ACT ninety seven
oh three is tuned specifically for the
pharmaceutical needs and works for both
788 and 787 types of analysis so again
what we're dealing with is a particle
counter and numerator so we're telling
you how many particles are seen at a
certain size or within a range typically
and the ones used for this purpose for
787 would be from roughly 1 micron up to
perhaps 600 the results are
it says here minutes but almost seconds
you're really getting results very
quickly and we're enumerating so we're
counting we're saying a size
we can't tell you what it is with just
this simple analysis oh we can't give
you some of the things you often might
want to know about particles morphology
the color the mass the composition well
this machine is basically giving you
quantification accounts so it is eight
counter as I said the only thing in this
world is that really we're dealing with
three-dimensional objects in most cases
in the real world so we have objects
that are definitely not round or
spherical there whatever might be
encountered bits of glass it's aluminum
fibers from garments all these types of
things might be present hopefully not
but have been certainly found in
injectables
well people have struggled with this for
a number of years in fact it goes back
several hundred years with light
microscopy how can you describe an
irregular shaped object so various
methods have been devised the largest
dimension or ferret's diameter have been
really commonly used in light microscopy
to in a sense reduce a three-dimensional
object to a description using one
dimension but it you could say well
that's not very accurate but also it
would take a lot more time especially if
you have a good number of objects to try
to quantify a large number of objects in
three dimensions so this is a form of
shorthand that gives us a pretty good
picture what's in the particular fluid
and if there's too many according to a
standard so in this case we're looking
at injectable pharmaceuticals we want to
know that it's below a certain limit
ideally you'd say gee if it's an
objective oh I'd like it to be zero and
that's certainly a good target but it's
also usually a very expensive one to
achieve so it has been found over years
that the limits that have been used here
6,000 per container for a 10 micron and
600 for container at 25 micron are
effective enough controls human body
can deal with that in a reasonable way
well when we use a light obscuration
counter we're doing something a little
different as I said we're kind of
looking at shadows and we're taking that
area that is projected onto our detector
and relating it to an equivalent
spherical size so when we talk about the
size given by a light obscuration sensor
we're looking at a surface area which
being in an area value for the
equivalence to describe it with a single
dimension if you go to the USP in 776
they discuss optical microscopy and they
talk about some of these methods and
when you look at those and you try to
set forward then what it would be for
that object using ferrets so we say okay
ferrets diameter well it's about that
link in equivalent and then we go and we
look at the projected area
excuse me maximum horizontal and then we
also look at projected area margins we
get different reacting different values
so it's very important to realize that
when you use these various methods be it
light microscopy or light obscuration or
Coulter counter as we're discussing that
a little bit later all these will give
in a sense slightly different variations
on the size value and this historically
has been reality even using light
microscopy for several hundred years so
it's important to really when you're
given a statement about a method and its
results that you clearly state the
method I use the light microscope
I used light observation I use the
Coulter counter all these would give
slightly different results and they need
to be indicated that way and that's
actually some of the advice we find in
1787 so again you'll end up then with
different actual dimensions so to speak
diameter is given by these different
methods so in 1787 they discussed that
and they say you know size is very
important size is a
attribute or something to know about an
object in the fluid so let's say size is
a particle attribute that has been
monitored historically remains a primary
descriptor some visible particles could
also be described as aggregates or
particles between one and hundred
microns based on and it gives several of
them that the ones we're going to focus
on are ECD so a new kind of terminology
thrown out there ECD the equivalent
circular diameter which is what your
time from light obscuration along this
cord which is commonly what you might
find in light microscopy or ESD the
equivalent spherical diameter which is
what you would find in the Coulter
method all these are valid but none of
them are quote wrong but again we're
trying to bend the rules here a bit
we're saying we're going to take a
three-dimensional object and describe it
with the one dimension well all these
will have been different slightly
different variations on the value given
so at the end suddenly 1787 they make
also this comment with any size
measurement the method used should be
specified so when we compare the optical
particle counter to a microscope
when we size that with microscope that
gets a bit subjective we find that it
depends on the particular type of
microscope it depends on the operator it
depends on how tired the operator is and
so forth when you use an electronic
method it's much more consistent and
repeatable and coarse between
instruments reproducible the particle
orientation movement is something that
electronics has to deal with also it's
not sitting there as a flat object on a
slide in microscope so long particles
can often be a little more of a
challenge but generally don't have that
many fibers when we speak of long
particles think mainly of fibres like
from garments or other sources that
would be in the fluid and we have to
think about calibration how do we relate
then this electronic response to the
real world two sizes of spherical
objects so we want that to be consistent
we want
and that's one of the things that the
electronic methods particle counting
definitely offers repeatability so we're
reporting a size but we're using optics
in the case and light obscuration and
you'll find differences in two other
methods what we do calibrate we use the
calibration material that is
commercially available and are traceable
to national organisations in the case of
the United States we talk about them as
being traceable to NIS T which is the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology and these are very very
beautiful precise microspheres and so we
have a quantity of those we certainly
are looking for a consistency and size
we can reset to the machine to record
the response and that becomes a
calibration based on multiple
introductions of sizes so we create a
calibration curve or response curve over
a range of sizes of interest or the
instruments capability again for light
obscuration that's typically something
on the order of 1 micron up to 3 4 500
600 microns so these types of
instruments then are focused to that
purpose and basically combine combines a
sensor to actually do the detection some
form of a sampling system to meter a
volume because again we're talking about
counts per unit volume so we want to
know that that's an accurate volume so
we have a metering system commonly a
syringe drawing system is used to
aspirate sample out of a vial or in the
container and then you have some form of
representation of the information
software used ideally with a convivial
methods built into them to allow the
consistent method and also that is
something that in terms of electronics
is a very well-defined and developed so
in the US and any cases around the world
we refer to the 21 CFR part 11 methods
to control access to control the methods
and consistency of software response so
you want all those aspects in a system
in terms of dealing with proteins some
of the modifications that have been put
into place are ways to deal with very
very small volumes or maybe even
material in a centrifuge or pointed to
something that's kind of hard to balance
on a flat standard so in order to make
that more effective we've designed into
the instrument ways to handle very very
small files and also in terms of working
with that to be able to work with the
minimum amounts the 0.2 milliliters so
an additional aspect is how do you
minimize dead volume how do you minimize
that the amount material needed to
initially wet or stimulate the sensor so
this allows the like one milliliter
material to be used to do the full pools
of about 0.2 milliliters each so various
efforts made to work toward small
volumes and accurately sample very very
small amounts of material so we've
talked about 787 I've also mentioned
1787
what are those about are they different
some way well yeah they are quite
different really because 787 functions
as a test seventy to eighty seven one
787 is an informative chapter in the USP
anything over the value of one thousand
as a chapter is informative it's
counseling it's good good advice it's
background material on a particular
method so we have as a companion to 787
very recently interviews the 1787
chapter which has quite a good bit of
information 787 was effective in August
of 2014 and it's basically normative or
and for dealing a method dealing with
the information needed for proteins set
out the method new limits 1787 is now
published and it has an effective date
of May 2015 so fairly soon and it is
listed as informative okay so it is
something that suggested you don't have
to do this but there's a lot of good
information in fact in that chapter so
it looks at various measurements for
proteins discusses a whole range of
technologies and describes those and
compares them with methods and purposes
so there's different concerns sometimes
when you look at protein for research
development and production all need
different maybe methodologies and so
those are touched on in this discussion
of proteins and analyzing them for
counting and for characterization of
particles so a very worthwhile chapter
well what are some of those methods and
what could be used to help analyze
material under 787 in parallel to it or
for other purposes memory for some
research purposes we're 787 doesn't
really apply 787 as its 788 is really
focused to a final dose form but often
people use that as a guideline in the
research and element side so 1787 talks
about an additional aspect and you start
to see this I think more in regulatory
world that the collection of data
outside of the typical 10 and 25 micron
data is recommended for proteins again
this is focused towards proteins so
collection of data and the tuna to 10
micron range is recommended not demanded
so it's not a requirement but it's
recommended and so they talk about him
what about two to five and maybe five
potatoes might be suggestible ranges to
look at in addition to what
acquire for information in 10 and 25 and
in the summary it talks about you know
how to use maybe the information you're
already getting doing the compendium
method the 787 method to kind of have a
additional insight into the production
consistency proteins can often be much
more difficult to have consistent
production and so maybe different
windows into that could be used so in
1787 it speaks about the correlation of
counts of particles from the overall
memories through bombers good boy
through the 25 micron size assess as
part of the compendium method and it may
make it possible to rely on the ellow
that slight obscuration determination
alone to reveal changes and trends in
manufacturing so it says use this
information you're already acquiring and
kind of use it to maybe not just passed
the test but maybe to do in a sense give
a sense of the heartbeat of the method
is it consistent from one week to the
next
in this situation overall control
strategy would be used to establish
action limits for particles greater than
10 microns which one exceeded would
trigger an investigation including the
characterization methods discussed in
this chapter so it's saying you know the
information could point to other aspects
of production or process control and and
they are encouraging and again 1787 is
recommendation normally encouraging
looking and using that data maybe even
think about alert or action limits based
on some of that to look at the process
and so it also speaks about some of the
difficulties with certain formulations
in the protein world even in the small
molecule world but certainly the protein
the world and it says the yellow light
obscuration method has some technical
limitations when used for analyzing
certain protein
types and often they change shape and
under pressure under vacuum with certain
temperatures proteins are much more
inconsistent you could say through the
analytical process so what can you do as
an alternate method well certainly one
very consistent method that's been in
place for again decades is the Coulter
counter method I wanted briefly
introduce you to that as we finish up
this discussion one of the aspects of a
lot of proteinaceous solutions to
suspensions really is that they are the
material semi-transparent it's almost a
majority water you could say and in a
fluid that is often aqueous or near
aqueous and so the difference the
contrast the refractive indices we're
talking about the terminology you could
use in the optical world is very very
limited the contrast the ability to see
it it's kind of like seeing something
gray in a fog so we don't really have a
perfect substitute for protein material
niste and other groups are working on
calibration materials but we really
don't have anything that effectively
represents that we have our very
accurate spheres that we have but those
again don't quite look like proteins and
they have different refractive indices
so what could we do we have again this
need to distinguish those and as an
optical response it's kind of again
dependent on having a good contrast to
that so in 787 it speaks about
alternative analytical methods and which
adequately developed some visible
particle limits well what are the other
methods and again 1787 discusses that
and this chapter points to alternate
orthogonal methods for investigating the
quantity the enumeration of particles in
a solution so line obscuration as we
mentioned starts around 1 micron the
culture counter has a wider range based
though on using different orifices in it
but it has a wide range and again it's
an old method in the sense of history
history it's developed in the 1940s and
certainly has been effective analyzing
the goods you know and last now what 60
years and it has capability of looking
through the range of visible sub visible
with sub micron with different offices
used in it in quick tests per container
limits at ten and twenty five microns
certainly and in voids because it is a
different method using a electrical flow
method as opposed to an optical method
so the transparency of the bodies that
you might run into being a proteins or
something else in a fluid are no longer
present an issue of refractive indices
so basically it's something that will
count and size in adhesion fluid and it
does this basically by moving the object
as part of fluid flow through an orifice
as an object moves through the orifice
it constrains an electric current flow
but the current flow is set up in the
medium and ions basically move from one
from anode to cathode in this design and
if you interrupt that by putting a chunk
of material in between through that
small orifice that's something that in
terms of flow of current can be detected
so we can get input back as particles
move through that opening because it
constricts or restricts the current flow
so that gives us an electronic pulse now
that pulse is something slightly
different from what you get then from
the light obscuration system and what
we're really giving then is an
equivalent volume and of course from a
volume you can determine
is an aspherical representation
determine a diameter so we can go ahead
and use that equivalent volume to tell
us also then the size of the object but
we have or avoid the issue of
transparency or near transparency of the
object you knew when you have any
optical methodology so the Coulter
method and this is a comment from one of
the posters in a protein Congress the
key advantage of the MS 4 which is the
Coulter's design culture cover design
model is ability to detect particles
that are undetectable by light based MFI
which is a imaging technique and Hyack
since detection does not rely on the
optical properties of the solution or
the particles so another key advantages
at the MS 4 can more accurately measure
the volume of asymmetrical particles and
that can be useful information the
volume that can be very helpful you can
look at the differences between a wrong
elongated object oval object versus
something spherical versus something
that is totally irregular so it has some
more information to give you about a
objects in a fluid and it covers quite a
wide range and can go down into the
nanometer range with the same
instruments both using them different
orifices all the way up into the fairly
large range into what and under the USP
terms they speak about as visible that
is greater than 100 microns so again
from the 1787 which is again an advisory
chapter in the USP they talk about the
information that could be used and
gained from light operation because that
is the primary method spoken about in
787 correlation and accounts of
particles from bombers through the 25
micron size assess as part of convenient
method may make it possible to rely on
hello determination alone to reveal
changes and trends and manufacturing so
again mr. very you know repeating that
commentary that information from the
method gives you the pass/fail certainly
so you have the ten micron 25 micron
limits but also consider using the
information given by the various
techniques by the light obscuration
technique to help as a process control
reflection in developing protein based
materials so kind of final summary then
how the USP 787 was effective as of the
1st of April actually 1st of August and
2014 it is specific to protein based
therapeutics so you cannot use it for
other types of materials only for a
protein based therapeutics it does
exclude vacuums or system the material
that's delivered through at some form of
a final filter as part of the let's say
the hypodermic structure might have a
filter in it then you would not be it
would be non atom and to use 787 the the
hike at 90 703 as a light obscuration
based system can satisfy those
requirements and within the software
there's various methods to create
procedures that can be very useful for
looking at the protein based materials
the culture counter is an alternate
technology and it has the ability to
work with higher concentrations and to
ignore the transparency however it does
require a presence of ions either
naturally in the material or in addition
as let's say a bit of salt or similar
addition into the solution sometimes
that can be a drawback sometimes
difficult to have a consistent material
consistent when you add anything to it
so if you add extra buffer to a
a therapeutic dose you'll find often it
changes that the proteins that might be
in aggregate form disassociate or other
aspects that resolve reverse so you have
to consider any time to change material
by adding by diluting by adding ions
anything like this you have to consider
is it changing the material that I
intended to look at in executing the
metal so with that I want to wrap up
this introduction to the 787 and 1787
and I appreciate your spending time day
and if you have questions certainly I
would encourage you to look at WW
article com for more information on both
of these methods and on 787 in general
and certainly feel free to contact me if
you have questions later on and with
that treaty and I'll turn it back to you
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session that I'd
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as you can and
our first question is how can accuracy
be shown within a method validation for
a protein based formulation
well accuracy I'm going to guess relates
to accuracy and counts that the accuracy
could have different meanings there I
think and generally again you would use
a
calibration methodology we don't have
something that emulates proteins
perfectly today again there are national
bodies working on that but at the moment
we do we have somewhat of a surrogate in
the type of either polystyrene beads or
glass beads to represent a spherical
object
unfortunately most proteins aren't
spherical so I'm not sure exactly in the
question what accuracy is going for but
I'm thinking probably we're talking
count and we do have count standards
based on spherical material here's your
next one should stir bars be used to
educate the sample I would not recommend
that again that would be something maybe
to determine the stir bar could have two
negative effects one can be certainly
that it changes the the material in the
sample because of the movement because
of the agitation the second problem can
be that again with proteins specifically
that they will tend to aggregate more
readily when you introduce a lot of
energy into the suspension and also
should there be any ferrous material
assuming it's a magnetic type of stir
bar it would be attracted to the bar and
therefore never be drawn drawn into the
sample and so you would not see metal
particles that have a ferrous content
they would be drawn to the stir bar and
never be drawn up into the instrument so
if you get a bit of a misleading sample
generally we avoid stir bars just
because they're difficult to keep clean
and to make sure they don't introduce
contamination and/or affect the process
sampling okay suppose the drug product
is a vial containing lyophilized protein
that is diluted in an IV vent prior to
administration what then are the allowed
limits of particles for a the drug
product file and be the infusion bag
containing the add
from product and lastly is the IV bag
considered to be a large volume drug
product the general council dealing with
lawful eyes material is that it needs to
be reconstituted and presented in the
final form as it would be presented to
the patient so this is kind of the the
leading direction of that and and it
makes it a little bit more difficult
first off any lawful eyes material has
to be reconstituted using whatever it
normally a physician or nurse would do
for the process so if it's going to go
into a bag then basically you need to
simulate or emulate that whole process
and again the focus was 787 one of the
reasons they put this container limit in
there is that they're trying to see that
the dosage that would be given in total
in a therapeutic step so I would
understand this and I'm not the on the
expert committee but I would understand
this to demand that you would
reconstitute it introduce it into the IV
bag and test the complete ensemble
that's a little bit difficult in the
sense that there are different IV bags
out there in different different
solutions so it's hard to make that an
absolute consistent framework but I
think that's no more of a problem and to
say well if I'm going to dilute any
material using my clean water in my lab
well in fact clean water is slightly
different from one lab to another even
maybe one day to another in that so I'm
not sure that's really a strong case
against this but again the intention for
the analysis is to see what the
patient's body is going to see when you
expect to have the 787 report updated in
the software for not the 97 O 3 plus I
believe that will be out dirt later this
month in
in April I'm not 100% sure that I know
it's feminine and just going through its
final verification and release so I
would say within the next 30 days thank
you our light obscuration instruments
destructive and can you collect fluent
and perform at another test on the
sample generally it's considered
destructive you could collect it the
problem is especially with proteins
you've now pulled it through the syringe
drive and you've you know created shear
forces and you know potentially have
maybe associated it with a previous
sample so it's very difficult to recover
and it depends on the type of test I
guess I wouldn't be succeeding it as to
whether or not it would affect the
sample but certainly you have to
consider does any of the method of
drawing the sample moving it through the
various tubing most of which is inert
chemically but still provides a certain
amount of shear force and and
pressurization as you push the sample
out of the syringe after it's been
pulled into it and that may affect
certain types of materials so you need
to do any further analysis with all that
in mind you know certainly probably a
simple chemical analysis could be done
but a lot of other things you need to be
very mindful of the fact that device
causes a certain expansion and
compression and that might affect the
inherent qualities of the protein 10 787
applied to a protein solution used and I
graz that have to meet 789 specs um
I don't think so I hadn't thought about
this but generally the focus on 787 is
as an injectable so eyedrops in other
words not an injection but eyedrops
would seem to be outside of that and so
you wouldn't be able to apply it as I
would interpret it even if it was a I
dropped it was you know again protein
based I think the focus would be limited
to injectables but it's it's an
interesting question and if we thought
of that aspect up to this time hey we
have time for one more question if the
Hyatt compatible with organic solvents
in most cases yes most of the weather
components are immune to solvents that
stainless steel and Teflon and glass it
would be good to know the exact solvent
there are a couple of rings that can be
tuned if you would say or chosen
particular materials to resist certain
organic solvents so it's a good
technical question the important thing
would be knowing exactly the solvent use
because there could be a couple of
choices calories versus light on for
example as materials to provide maximum
resistance to an organic solvent thank
you Joe I would like to thank our
sponsor Beckman Coulter for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through October 2015
October 8th 2015 the slides are
available to download as PDF you'll
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay and we invite you to Ford
that announcement your colleagues you
may have missed today's live event see
you next time bye